donald trump and rudy giuliani are just
at the beginning of their legal troubles
you heard a couple of weeks ago that
rudy giuliani is under
serious legal pressure for his false
claims about
dominion voting machines and their
alleged
role in the 2020 presidential election
now donald trump and rudy giuliani are
being sued
for their role in inciting the january
6th riots and it's not just one lawsuit
there is going to be
in theory lots of legal money to be made
by lawyers defending these guys over the
next few years
if they actually pay their legal bills
let's talk about the two lawsuits that
are going on
first and foremost the naacp
uh has sued rudy giuliani and
donald trump as well as two white
supremacist groups
citing their role in the january 6th
insurrection
in addition to this a mississippi
democratic representative
benny thompson in his personal capacity
has also sued donald trump and rudy
giuliani this lawsuit was filed
yesterday morning in federal district
court for washington d.c
it says trump and rudy in collaboration
with the proud boys and oath
keepers conspired to incite the riot
to keep congress from certifying the
results of the 2020 presidential
election
and it says that their doing so
specifically violated the klu klux kla
sorry the ku klux klan act which is a
statute designed
to protect both formerly enslaved
black americans as well as lawmakers in
congress from white supremacist
violence representatives hank johnson
and bonnie watson coleman are going to
be joining the litigation
as plaintiffs in the coming days and the
lawsuit really spells out
not just you know one of the one of the
i don't know about interesting but
one of the notable aspects of the case
made against donald trump by the house
impeachment managers
in trump's second impeachment trial
which concluded on saturday of course
with donald trump's acquittal
was that the focus understandably
because trump was the one
being tried was on things donald trump
said and did
but when you step back from that a
little bit and you see the bigger
picture which includes rudy giuliani
it includes giuliani and jenna ellis
flying around the country holding these
bogus voter fraud hearings
which were not nobody was even under
oath they were not
formal hearings in any and any real
sense of of the word
that's a bigger part of the entire thing
and of course rudy giuliani talking
about trial by combat on january 6th
certainly a big part of what what we are
expecting
to see as part of this uh lawsuit
and uh this is admittedly a
statute the ku klux klan ku klux klan
uh act that um this is this is not uh
frequently used or cited but it does at
least
superficially appear to be relevant here
and it specifically is for bringing
civil actions these are uh lawsuits
these are not criminal charges now
separately as you know donald trump is
under criminal investigation
in the state of georgia for that phone
call he made to georgia republican
officials asking them to find
11 780 votes i believe is the exact
number the number he needed to
win the state of georgia instead of joe
biden
um we know of possible criminal
investigations happening
in new york so this is likely going to
go on for some time now as far as the
lawsuit
for trump and rudy's inciting of the
riots
there is a real question there about a
possible class action for collective
trauma i had a class action attorney
email me yesterday saying
it would be really difficult who exactly
has standing to be party
to that class action i mean there's
certainly some some questions there
uh but that is that is an interesting
legal question
there are going to be legal problems for
donald trump and people around him for a
very long time
and there is no doubt that for some
period
trump and and even the republican party
is widely speaking going to dodge
accountability in all ways in 2022
we will see for the first time
electorally whether some of these uh
people that came to power
on the coattails of trump i'm of course
talking about
the uh i don't know what what what to
call them exactly but
madison cothor and marjorie taylor
greene and lauren bober
um we are go if they got re-elected
that would be a big sign that this
trumpian wing
is not going to suffer any consequences
for what they did in 2020
and we know that much of the american
public
has a short memory and that they may
have moved on to who knows what will be
going on in 2022 as far as trump is
concerned trump's legal problems aren't
going away
even if this specific lawsuit isn't
going to be more than
a small thorn in his side there may be a
hundred thorns
uh could be a sort of death of a
thousand paper cut sort of situation
and uh certainly donald trump is going
to be racking up significant legal bills
whether he will pay them as always
remains to be seen
one of our sponsors is privacy a free
service that protects your credit and
debit card
i use privacy every time i buy something
online i installed the app on my phone
and the privacy desktop browser
extension
now when i pay for anything privacy
autofills a virtual
credit card number the money's taken out
of my bank account i don't have to give
out my real card number or banking info
to anyone
you can create and delete the virtual
cards anytime
i especially love it for free trials
because i can destroy the virtual card
number
as soon as i give it to the company and
i know i won't be charged in the future
privacy also has a feature called shared
cards
which makes it easy to split payments
with friends parents can manage a
virtual card for their kid
with spending limits businesses can
manage virtual cards
for employees to use for company
expenses there are premium plans
available but privacy's regular service
is totally free to use
and right now they'll give you five
dollars just for signing up when you go
to privacy.com
pacman the link is underneath this video